MALE SPEAKER: Hi,
thanks for coming.
I'm very pleased to have
Greil Marcus here today.
Greil is one of the
world's first rock critics
and a native of the Bay Area.
Grew up in Menlo Park.
And sort of knew Bob Weir,
and sort of knew Jerry Garcia,
but not claiming any
great credit in that one.
So he went to Berkeley
in American studies.
And in 1975, wrote a
book, "Mystery Train,"
which is used in
college studies now,
including by our two
videographers here
who studied him in school.
He also wrote for "Rolling
Stone" at the very beginning.
Also "Creem" and
the "Village Voice."
Some of his other books
are "Lipstick Traces,"
"Invisible Republic," "The
History of Rock and Roll
in 10 Songs," and his current
book, which is on sale here,
"Three Songs, Three
Singers, Three Nations."
The number keeps coming down.
I'm hoping the next book
will be one song that
tells you everything you need
to know about rock and roll.
So please welcome Greil Marcus.
[APPLAUSE]
GRIEL MARCUS: Thanks, Bob,
and thank you for coming.
So I'm here to talk about
this very small book called
"Three Songs, Three
Singers, Three Nations."
And it came out of
a series of lectures
that I was asked to give
at Harvard a few years ago.
There was supposed
to be three lectures.
So I thought, OK,
I'll pick three songs.
And what I wanted
to do was to take
songs that seemed as if
they didn't have authors,
as if they were just--
came out of the air.
And there are a lot of American
folk songs that feel like that,
or that are like
that, songs where
it's impossible to
trace their origins.
There's no known composer.
There's no original.
So there's no version you can
say, well, that's just a copy.
If there's no original,
there's no copy.
These are just songs
that are common property.
I think of them as
commonplace songs.
And what I was interested
in was not just
songs like a folk song--
say, "East Virginia--"
or let's see-- a
blues song, like "Poor
Boy, Long Way From Home,"
songs that are just in the air.
I wanted to take songs
that felt like that,
but weren't necessarily
anonymous, weren't necessarily
authorless.
And I ended up with three songs.
The first one I talked
about was Bob Dylan's
"Ballad of Hollis Brown--"
obviously not a folk song,
not a song with
an unknown author.
A very specific person wrote it
at a very specific time, put it
out in a particular
album, and there it was.
But it always had
the feeling of being
a song that was handed down from
generation to generation, so
that even if there were an
actual author at some point,
that person would have
been completely forgotten.
It's a song about a farmer.
We don't know anything
about him except his name,
because it's mentioned
in this song.
And in the very, very end, in
the last verse of the song,
South Dakota is mentioned.
But otherwise, it's
just completely generic.
There's a farmer.
His farm is failing.
There isn't enough food
to feed his family.
No one will help him.
He has no friends.
And he ends up killing himself
and his wife and his children.
And it's the kind of song that
always carries with it the aura
of the Great Depression.
And if you go to YouTube and
you look at videos that fans
have made, they all
show dust storms,
and they all show Okies fleeing
the Dust Bowl, and foreclosures
of buildings.
And all the pictures
are from the '30s.
You're looking at
Dorothea Lange.
You're looking at Ben Shahn,
all these famous, iconic images
from that time, because it
just has that feeling to it.
Except it wasn't about
the Great Depression.
It was set right in
its moment, 1964,
when it was written
and released.
But people thought,
oh, this must
be about the Great Depression.
Well, the thing is,
with a family farm,
the depression is a year
away for almost everybody.
That's the nature of
having a small farm that's
totally dependent on
itself and on the market
and on the weather, forces
that can't be controlled.
So it has that feeling of
being a song that maybe
was from the 19th century,
maybe after the Civil War, maybe
before it, but most
likely the 1890s
when, in fact, there was a
horrendous depression that
swept through the Midwest.
It has that feeling--
or the '30s.
The last thing it feels
like is the 1960s.
But it's a story about a man
who kills his family and then
himself that appears in this
country every year or so.
Every year or so, you'll
see a small story.
Maybe it will be two,
three, four column inches,
but that's all, about a man
in Florida, most recently
two years ago, who killed
himself and his family
for whatever reasons.
And in this case, it was
economic destitution,
the same as in the song.
So that was something
that was interesting--
a song that felt as
if it had no author,
but had a very specific author.
And I wanted to play around
with how and why Bob Dylan might
have created a song,
made a song this way.
As it happened, he used a melody
from a very ancient-- 400,
500-year-old-- folk song called
"Pretty Polly," a common song
all through Appalachia,
all through the south,
from the 18th century forward.
And he has a very
distinct cadence,
pounding kind of melody.
It's full of foreboding.
And you just have
a sense of force,
and something terrible
is about to happen.
All that's carried
in the melody.
So he took the melody
from that old folk song
and wrote new words to it.
So that was one example.
Another example was
a song that really
is what's called a
folk lyric song, where
a certain person learned
this song at a certain time,
but he learned it
from a friend who
had learned it from an uncle.
And the uncle was
dead, so there's
no way of asking who
the uncle heard it from.
This was around 1900
when a college student
named Bascom Lamar Lunsford
was waiting for a train
to take him back to
Asheville, North Carolina.
And his college friend,
a guy named Fred Moody,
taught him this song.
And it was called "I Wish I
Was a Mole in the Ground."
It's one of the
strangest songs in all
of American music-- all of
American iconography, really.
And there isn't a
single element in it,
except one, that can
be traced to any place
or any time or any person.
A folk lyric song
means verses-- a song
that's made out
of verses or maybe
just single lines,
maybe even an image,
that come from different songs.
And they're called floating
verses or floating lines.
And a person will take pieces
of all these various songs, all
these familiar elements,
and put them together
in his or her own way and
say, well, this is my song.
I made this song.
I wrote this song.
But in fact, there won't be
a single original word in it.
It's the arrangement.
It's the presentation that's
original, if anything is.
But here is a song
that has lines
in it that are utterly strange.
It's a song that goes back
and forth, verse by verse,
between essentially
overthrowing the world and sex.
Every other verse is
about destruction or love.
And it starts out, I wish
I was a mole in the ground.
I wish I was a
mole in the ground.
If I was a mole in the ground,
I would root that mountain down.
And I wish I was a
mole in the ground.
So here is someone who's
saying, I wish I was blind,
I was this ugly, hideous
creature scurrying
under the earth kind of thing,
that if anybody sees me,
they'd want to kill me.
And I'm going to burrow
under that mountain-- which
means power, which
means the state, which
means the north after the
Civil War, which means anything
that you feel oppresses you.
And I'm going to burrow
under that mountain,
and I'm just going to
paw away at it until I
bring the entire mountain down.
It's a fantasy of revolution,
that one little mole
can bring the entire structure
of power, whatever it might be,
down.
And you go from that
verse to a verse
about a woman named
Tempi, or Kempi, who
is running over a hill.
And she wants a $9
shawl, and she's
going to let her
hair hang down, which
is an age old American
image for making love.
All these things
are going to happen.
You go back and
forth between I wish
I was a lizard in
the spring, I wish
I was a lizard in the spring.
Again, being a
mole is not enough.
You want to be a lizard?
And that verse,
again, is a fantasy
of a basement, a fantasy
of not being seen,
of being there but not there.
And then you go back to
Tempi coming over the hill,
waving a $40 bill.
And the singer says, baby,
where you been so long.
Now, American folk
song is-- and I'll
be getting to more of this in a
couple minutes-- American folk
song is made up of all
different kinds of codes.
Baby let your hair hang
down means let's have sex.
Where you been so
long means who were
you sleeping with last night.
That's what it means.
That's the only thing it means.
She comes over the
hill with a $40 bill,
and I say baby, where
you been so long.
You want to translate that?
That means she's
been on the streets,
and she's come back with $40.
And it all rushes by very fast.
That's the only
thing in the song
that is specific to
anything-- a $40 bill.
And in its way, it's just as
odd as wanting to be a mole.
What is a $40 bill?
I listened to this
song-- and I've
loved this song for more
than 40 years-- 46 years.
I can really date to
when I first heard it.
And it was only in the past
few years I thought, $40 bill?
Who's ever heard of a $40 bill?
And thanks to this magic
tool called the internet,
you can actually
just go find out.
And so I did.
And boom, the $40 bill was
issued by the Continental
Congress in 1778.
It was in circulation for
only a couple of years.
That's the only
time there has been
a $40 bill in the history
of the United States.
Just stunning that you
could find this out.
And there wasn't
one any other time.
It was obviously some
bizarre anachronism.
And you go right to, dare
I say, Google Images,
and there will be a $40 bill.
And again, the
Continental Congress--
it's not as if the country
actually had a name.
One of the bills says the United
States of Northern America.
That didn't catch on.
But they were trying.
That's official US currency.
And if you go through
normal channels--
I decided at one point
I needed a $40 bill
so I could use it as an
illustration in this book.
And taking something off Google
Images wasn't good enough.
I had to get an actual $40 bill.
So I tried the Smithsonian.
And they did a search.
They couldn't find anything.
I tried the Library of Congress.
I tried the National Archives.
Everything came up zero.
Nobody knew.
Nobody could find out
anything about it.
Nobody had it.
So I had to go to eBay.
And within a couple of
days, there was a $40 bill.
It was really not
very difficult,
and it wasn't even
that expensive.
Given what I had to pay
for it, if you figure
a $40 bill and you
factor in inflation
for 250-- 270 years,
whatever it's been,
275 years, that
$40 bill would be
worth a lot of money,
a whole lot more money
than I had to pay for it.
So I got a $40
bill, and I managed
to have it shot and sent to the
publisher, and that was that.
But that's the only
thing that's specific.
And it's the only
thing that says
this song, or at least
one element of this song,
is as old as the
memory of a $40 bill.
It doesn't mean this song began
to come together in the 1770s.
But it means that at some point,
someone who's putting this song
together takes a line from
another song, or maybe a poem,
or maybe something this
person heard in an argument
or in a bar.
You tried to pay
with a $40 bill?
There ain't no such
thing as a $40 bill.
$40 bill-- what an
interesting idea.
I'll stick this in my song,
maybe just as another image
of unlikeliness.
I wish I was a mole.
I wish I was a lizard.
I have a $40 bill.
Maybe it fits that way.
Maybe it's more
specific than that.
So maybe that means
that somebody remembered
when there was a $40 bill.
So maybe it could be the 1820s.
You can't understand
anything about this song
in terms of musicology.
It's just there.
In 1928, this man,
Bascom Lamar Lunsford,
who was a college student when
he learned this song in 1900,
recorded it.
He was a strange character--
North Carolina lawyer, judge,
newspaper editor,
Democratic Party operative.
During the First
World War, he was
hired by the Justice
Department to chase down
draft dodgers in New York City.
God knows why they had to
bring him to New York City,
but they did.
He actually began
recording in the '20s.
Eleanor Roosevelt was
a great folk music fan.
She invited him to perform
at the White House in 1936
for President Roosevelt and
the King and Queen of England.
And that was one of the
high points of his life.
And he became a
folklorist, and he
recorded hundreds
and hundreds of songs
for the Library of Congress
along with commercial records.
And so he made a
record of this song,
"I Wish I Was a
Mole in the Ground."
And in the '50s and the '60s,
when there was a folk revival,
a huge revival of interest
in old folk songs,
people began to sing it,
and it began to travel,
began to be heard.
All sorts of people
tried to record it.
And now it's a commonplace song.
It's there.
But this is a song that
absolutely has no author.
It has performers.
But it is a song whose
origins are completely lost,
except for that $40 bill.
The other song I wanted
to fool around with
was a song that I first
heard, as most people
who know it first heard
it, I think, in 1994.
There is a film director
named Terry Zwigoff,
and his first movie
was called "Crumb."
And it was about
the comics artist R.
Crumb, one of the most scabrous
and obscene and hilarious and
adventurous comics artists
that the United States has
produced in the last century.
And he's presented-- he would
be about my age now, somewhat
older, so say he's
in his mid 70s now.
And this movie is made in the
early 1990s when he's still
living in San Francisco.
And you follow him,
and you hear interviews
with people who know
him or are close to him.
And he talks a lot.
And you also get
to know his family.
And his family is a ruin.
His parents are long gone.
He has two brothers.
They're both crazy.
They're both commitable,
although they're not committed.
And they're people who live
in hovels and never leave.
They're just ruined people.
Crumb-- R. Crumb, Robert
Crumb, we meet him.
And he's cranky, and
he doesn't like people,
and he just complains.
I've corresponded with him
occasionally over the years.
He's incredibly funny.
He's just uproarious.
And he corresponds by letters,
by handwritten letters.
But he's a professional
cartoonist.
His lettering is just
wonderful to read.
It's like reading a cartoon.
And it's just great to
listen to his voice.
It comes through.
And it's all about, I hate this.
Nothing is-- this is
an insult to humanity.
I can't believe you
mentioned that to me.
And you don't feel like
he's actually angry.
This is just how he talks.
But in the movie,
you get to know him.
He is the ultimate misanthrope.
He does not like people.
He doesn't like the weather.
He doesn't like the
way the concrete feels
on his shoe leather.
There's just nothing he likes.
And you meet him as
an unpleasant person
who doesn't want to
live in the world,
like his brothers,
who essentially
don't live in the world.
But he does live in the world.
He does function in the world.
But he doesn't like it.
And then there's this
scene where he's in a room,
and the room is lined with
shelves of 78 RPM records
from the '20s and '30s.
And when he was in his early
20s, he was a record collector.
He collected old blues and
country records from the South.
And he would go
through the south,
like many record collectors did.
And he would essentially knock
on doors in poor white sections
or in black sections
of small towns,
and he'd say, do you have
any old records that you'd
like to sell, the premise being
that there might be people who
had old records that they
just hadn't gotten around
to throwing out.
And there might be things
that you would really
want-- something
incredibly rare,
something that no one had
ever heard of that turned out
to be beautiful and unique.
And you would pay $0.25
for these records,
and maybe up to $1.
If you paid over $2,
you were considered
some kind of
dilettante, some kind
of rich kid who came down--
instead of collecting stamps,
bought somebody
else's collection.
So that was frowned on.
And he did that.
He went from door to door.
He knocked on doors.
And he amassed this collection,
this extraordinary collection
of 78 records.
And so you see him, and
he's there in a little room.
And he goes up to the shelf,
and he pulls a record off,
and he puts it on a phonograph.
And then he lies down on
a kind of cot, a day bed.
And he lies down, and
he closes his eyes,
and this song begins to play.
And it's just from
another world.
It is one of the strangest
things I'd ever heard,
and I'm sure most of the people
in the theater had ever heard.
And you just don't know.
What are you listening to?
This music sounds as if
it came out of the ground.
It barely sounds like
it was sung by a person.
It sounds like it was sung by
a dead person, a person who's
trying to talk to you from
the other side of death.
All this comes
through instantly.
And he's lying there,
and he's saying,
sometimes I listen
to music like this
and I feel this is the
voice of ordinary people,
common people-- and
he says that kind
of disdainfully--
common people making
a connection with eternity.
And then he's embarrassed by
how open he's left himself.
He says, making a
connection to eternity,
or whatever you
want to call it--
that I should entertain
a notion as corny, as
human, as eternity.
And you're listening
to the song,
and you're saying, yeah, right.
That's right.
This is somebody making
a connection to eternity.
I could never have
put it any better.
I left the theater-- and I'm
sure I wasn't the only one
when that movie was over--
and I drove straight
to the nearest
record store, hoping
there might be a soundtrack
album to this movie,
and that this song
might be on it.
And it was.
So I'm going to play you this
song, and then talk about it
some, and maybe play it again.
[MUSIC - GEESHIE WILEY, "LAST
KIND WORDS BLUES"]
So that's the song that I heard.
I got the soundtrack album.
I played the song
over and over again.
Geeshie Wiley was the
name of the performer.
And I found out pretty
quickly that in 1930, she
had made records for the
Paramount Recording Company
in Grafton, Wisconsin.
She recorded a lot
of blues singers,
mostly from Mississippi,
but from elsewhere, too
in the late '20s and early '30s.
And she had recorded by herself
and with a partner named Elvie
Thomas, E-L-V-I-E Thomas.
And they had made
records together.
Elvie Thomas made one
under her own name.
Geeshie Wiey made three
Some were Geeshie and Elvie.
And what you found
out almost immediately
if you began to try
and dig into this
was that nobody knew
anything about these people
at all-- absolutely nothing.
You can presume because
their names and their records
and their voices that two
people, at least who were
calling themselves
by these names,
existed at this point
in time in 1930.
But that's all there was.
There was nothing.
Nobody knew the real
names of these people,
because Geeshie
is not a real name
and Elvie is not a real name.
Those are nicknames.
Nobody knew where
they were from.
Nobody knew when they were born.
Nobody knew when they died,
presuming that they had.
Nobody knew anything,
absolutely nothing.
These were the ultimate
phantoms of American art.
And this is a song that
captivated hundreds
and thousands of people.
And blues researchers
began to search the south.
And some had been
searching for a lot
long before this song appeared
in Terry Zwigoff's movie.
And no one had found
out anything at all.
It was a mystery
beyond mysteries.
Who are these people?
How did they come
to be recorded?
How did a song this
singular, this strange,
this ghostly and spooky
and threatening, beautiful
and captivating-- how did a
song like this come to be?
Who could create this song?
And long before there
were any answers--
and there are answers now,
because a writer named
John Jeremiah Sullivan spent
three, four years doing
research of extraordinary
ambition and reach,
which essentially meant
finding the greatest living
authority on early blues,
a man named Mack McCormick,
who lived in Houston-- recently
died-- going to visit him,
asking if he knew anything
about these people.
And having him
say, well, in fact,
he interviewed Elvie Thomas in
1961 in Houston where he lived.
He had heard about this
person who he'd never
heard of himself, had
never heard her records,
didn't really know
anything about her.
But he had heard from
another blues singer
that there was an old blues
singer living in Houston.
She had made some
records, and maybe she
was the sort of person
he'd want to talk to.
And he had gone to talk to her.
Well, that was 1961.
That was a long time ago.
And he had the
interview somewhere.
He always transcribed his
notes immediately and always
wrote up a transcript.
He had it somewhere.
But he said, I live with
what I call the monster.
And the monster was
his entire house
filed according to
an arcane system
that nobody could
ever understand
of books, of
records, of articles
of his own research, his own
transcripts, his own files,
hundreds of thousands
and tens of thousands
of artifacts in a kind of
Augean stables of research.
And he said, I don't
where that might be,
but I do remember
talking to her.
So here is the Rosetta
stone, but I'll never
be able to find it.
So with a couple of
hints that Sullivan
was able to get
from McCormick, he
began to go through
census records
and police records and
trial records in Houston
starting around 1900.
Ultimately, over several
years and over the discovery
of the transcript of
this interview, which
included the details of
this person's real name,
Geeshie Wiley's real name,
when this person, Elvie Thomas,
was born, and many other
details, including the fact
that while she was
born in Houston,
while she grew up in Houston,
lived there her adult life,
in her 40s, she came to
San Francisco in 1939,
and she worked for the
key railroad, which
means the streetcar system.
And she was here
until the late '40s
when she went back to Houston.
Turned out she was born in 1891.
And one of the strangest
and most evocative things
that she said in the interview
she did in 1961-- when
she had become religious,
she looked upon blues
as her sinful days.
She didn't want
to talk about it.
She was a different person then.
She hadn't found the Lord then,
who she called the master.
But now I serve the master.
I don't do that sort
of thing anymore.
But she was born in 1891.
And she said that
she learned how
to play blues guitar when
she was 11 years old, which
is to say in 1902.
And she said there
were blues even then.
In other words, Mack
McCormick had found a person,
and now John Jeremiah Sullivan,
reading the transcripts
of this interview,
had found a person
who remembered when there
was no such thing as blues.
She could say yes, I remember
when there were blues, which
means when I was
seven, when I was six,
there was no such thing.
I had never heard
anything like that before.
No one had heard anything
like that before.
This music, in fact,
did appear in the 1890s.
And in a way, it was
something in Texas,
something in
Mississippi, something
in South Carolina when
someone would report
hearing an eerie, strange,
unearthly, unhealthy, evil kind
of music where there wasn't
singing, there was moaning,
and there weren't
notes on the guitar
so much as smears and slurs.
And what is this?
Where did it come from?
This is not white folklorists
from Harvard University
coming down to the south and
saying, oh, this is so strange.
What is it?
This is people like
W.E.B. Du Bois.
This is people like W.C.
Handy, the so-called father
of the blues.
These are African Americans
who are Southerners
who are being confronted
with his music and saying,
this is not of this Earth.
This is like what
we just listened to.
So John Sullivan
was able to find out
when Elvie Thomas was born.
He was able to
reconstruct her life.
And this took years.
And it involved meeting people
who were members of the church
that she belonged
to, talking to people
who knew her, talking
to her pastor,
reconstructing her life.
One of the things
he found out was
that she was a lifelong lesbian,
that she lived with a woman
most of her life who was her
wife except under the law.
She never wore dresses.
She only wore pants.
He found out what brand
of cigarettes she rolled.
He was able to find out a lot.
And about Geeshie Wiley, he was
able to find out her real name,
Lilly Mae, Lilly Mae Wiley.
He was able to find out where
she was born-- in Louisiana--
when she was born, in
1908, and that they
had become musical
partners in around 1928,
1929 when Geeshie
Wiley was only 20
and Elvie Thomas would have
been in her late 30s, a really
unusual partnership.
And they traveled together
in 1930 to Wisconsin
to make records.
And then they disappeared.
And what Sullivan
was not able to do
was to find out what happened
to Geeshie Wiley after 1931.
He found out that
in 1931, she had
been arrested for
killing her ex-husband,
for stabbing him in the neck.
And he was not able
to find out anything
that happened after that.
Was there a trial?
Was she convicted?
Did she go to prison?
Was she acquitted?
Was the case thrown out?
Nothing.
And she disappears after that.
In the interview that
Elvie Thomas gave in 1961,
she says I heard she was in
Oklahoma about five, six, seven
years ago in Oklahoma.
That would have been
in the early '50s.
But that was all she knew.
And she wasn't even
sure about that.
So she disappeared again.
And when I was talking
with John Sullivan--
because we consulted
back and forth all
through this research of his,
mainly because 20 years ago,
I wrote a piece for
a magazine called
"Oxford American" about the
song that we just listened to.
And I tried to
talk about the fact
that it wasn't just the mystery
of nobody knowing anything
about these people
that was interesting.
What was more interesting
was the mystery in the song.
The song itself was a mystery.
Anyway, it turned
out the fact checker
they assigned to this article
was John Jeremiah Sullivan.
So years later, when the
bug of this song bit him,
he got in touch, and we began
to bat ideas back and forth.
And he was not able to find out
anything about her after that.
And he just mentioned,
I don't even
know when and where she died.
And then he said, if she died,
he said she'd be 106 today.
It's possible.
It's possible that she's alive.
It's possible that
in 1994, somebody
said to her-- when she was
an old woman-- said to her,
I saw this movie, and they
played your song in it.
Maybe she went to see the movie.
You begin to
fantasize about this.
Right about this time,
I was telling my wife
about the call I had just
had with John Sullivan.
And she said,
that's interesting.
Our doctor, who she
had just been to see,
mentioned that
his oldest patient
was a black woman who was 106.
And light bulbs are
going off like crazy.
Oh my god.
Here in-- he's a
Berkeley doctor,
but Elvie Thomas
was in San Francisco
for 10 years in the 1940s.
Why shouldn't she
end up in Berkeley?
So I called him.
And I said, your patient--
you have a patient who's 106.
He said, yeah, Bertha Johnson.
Oh, OK, Bertha Johnson.
He said, why do you ask?
And I told him.
And he said, oh, that's not her.
He said, but she did sing
with Louis Armstrong.
The jokes history plays on us.
And yet what is so
fascinating about this song,
particularly looking
for authorless songs,
songs that just seem to be part
of the landscape, that just
seem to emerge from it, is that
here is a song with a melody
that nobody recognizes
played in a minor key, which
was completely
uncharacteristic of blues,
and with lines in it that come
from countless other songs that
are just generic-- they're the
essence of what it means to be
a commonplace song-- that you
quote from some other song,
lines like-- and maybe you
caught it-- my mother told me.
Now, in blues, there's
only one time when
your mother tells you anything.
She doesn't tell you when
you're about to get married.
She doesn't tell you when you're
about to leave home and seek
your fortune.
Your mother only tells you
something just before she died.
And that's the way
this line goes.
My mother told me,
just before she died.
There's another verse when she
mentions the Mississippi River.
And again, in blues and
in old country music,
when you mention the
Mississippi River,
there's something you have
to say about the Mississippi
River.
You have to say
it's deep and wide.
And after you've said
the Mississippi River,
you know it's deep
and wide, then
you can go say
something of your own
if you have the
imagination to do that.
So it has these elements.
I went to the depot.
I looked up at the sun.
That's from hundreds of songs.
And what comes after
that-- and one song goes,
I went to the depot.
I looked up at the sun.
Sometimes, it's the
sign telling you when
the trains are going to arrive.
In one song, it says,
I went to the depot.
I looked up at the sign.
It said good times here,
but better down the road.
OK.
That's interesting.
When Geeshie Wiley sings the
line I went to the depot,
I looked up at the sun,
said train don't come,
going to be some walking done.
Just something she
wanted to put in there.
That's what she put in.
But there are also
lines in this song
that have never appeared
as far as anybody
has been able to find in any
other song, or for that matter,
in a poem or a novel
anywhere, lines
that seem as if they had to
come from one person at one time
only-- from this woman in
Geeshie Wiley, and that was it.
Because no one else had ever
come up with these images.
And then there were variations
on commonplace verses
that again were twisted and
distorted so that they would
create an aura, they
would create a mood,
they'd create an atmosphere
that was different,
that was complete,
that was total,
and an atmosphere of death.
It starts out the last kind
words I hear my daddy say.
Lord, the last kind words
I hear my daddy say.
That's the whole first verse.
It sets you up.
All right.
What are they?
What did he say?
He says something that, again,
no one had ever heard before.
He says, if I die, if I
die in the German war,
I want you to send my body--
send it to my mother-in-law.
It's hard to understand.
The words aren't
altogether clear.
But when I first
heard that, I thought,
this is the ultimate
mother-in-law joke,
or else he really loved
his mother-in-law.
And also, it's very spooky
for us listening today.
If I die, if I die in the German
war-- this is recorded in 1930.
She doesn't know there's going
to be another German war.
So it unsettles time for us.
It turns it into a
wheel, makes it spin.
And then the next verse is
so brilliantly constructed.
And I'll play the song again.
Listen to the way she
takes a single syllable.
Most often, it's the word "I,"
but it doesn't have to be.
But she takes a single
syllable or a phoneme,
and she stretches
it out all the way
across what for any other
singer would be an entire line.
And she just holds
that note in the air
until you're so captivated by
the sound that she's making,
you may forget to even hear
what words she's singing.
Because it doesn't matter.
Because the atmosphere of death
that she is creating around
this song in every single
verse and every note
is so complete that you
don't need words to explain
to you what the song is about.
The next verse is if I get
killed, if I get killed.
And she has constructed
this so perfectly.
If she were to say if I get
killed, if I get killed,
it would take the weight--
it would take the impact away
from the word killed.
Because the word "if" has its
own body, has its own strength.
But she dispenses with the
I. He says, if I get killed,
if I get killed.
You got a very soft
opening, and then
a hard consonant, the k--
if I get killed, killed.
So kill comes across-- if I
get killed, if I get killed.
And then again, she goes
off into an area where
no one's ever been before-- if
I get killed, if I get killed,
please don't bury my soul.
Just leave me out.
Let the buzzards eat me whole.
All right.
OK.
That goes back thousands
and thousands of years
to when early settlements,
Neolithic settlements in Turkey
and other places, their form
of burial was to take the dead,
leave them outside the
walls of the settlement,
let the buzzards
pick the bones clean,
and only then dispose of the
bones in a ritualistic manner
that we would recognize.
That's what people did.
And that goes back.
Whether that is a
human race memory, what
Hume would call a
collective memory,
whether it's a story that
she was told in her childhood
that passed down over
the centuries, who knows.
But in any case, it's there, and
it's never appeared in any song
that anybody knows.
But she can pull the string.
When she gets to the verse
the Mississippi River,
you know it's deep and
wide, the conventional way
to finish that verse is to
say I can stand right here
and see my baby
on the other side.
See, Mississippi River,
it's deep and wide,
but I love my baby so much
that I can stand here,
and I can see her
on the other side,
because my heart is
filled with love,
and it's giving me
extraordinary eyesight,
and I can see all the way
across the Mississippi River.
And that's not what she says.
And this is a woman of
a mind that isn't ours,
that is hers, who thinks
differently than we do,
who sees things
differently than we do.
She says, I can
stand right here,
see my face from the other side.
That is stranger.
She is standing here.
She sees her face on the
other side of the river,
but she is seeing her
face from the other side
of the river, which means
she's in two places at once
and seeing her own face all
the way across the Mississippi
River.
And that destabilizes the song.
That opens up a trap
door in the song.
And she follows it
with the next verse.
What you do to me, baby,
it never gets out of me.
And that couplet may have
appeared in other blues songs.
I've never heard it.
It's just a moment of
extraordinary warmth,
tenderness.
It's incredibly erotic.
It's just this blessing right
there in the first two lines
of the song.
And she says, I may not see you
when I cross the deep blue sea.
The deep blue sea--
again, talking
about codings and blues-- the
deep blue sea means death.
When you cross
the deep blue sea,
you are going to the other side.
You are going to die.
And you're supposed to
say I know I'll see you
when I cross the deep blue sea.
And it's so mandated
in the nature of blues
that any number of people who
have transcribed this song
and put the lyrics
up on the internet
say I know I'll see you when
I cross the deep blue sea.
That's what she ought to say.
It just isn't what she says.
Everybody in this
song has to be dead.
The last kind words
I hear my daddy say.
In blues, daddy usually
means lover or husband.
It doesn't mean father.
But it could mean father here.
My mother, just before she died.
I can see my face
on the other side.
I'm already dead.
I may not see you when I
cross the deep blue sea.
Everybody in this song is
dead, including the singer.
And if you listen-- if you
allow yourself to be taken in
by her guitar solos at
the beginning of the song
and in the middle-- you
will hear that same sense
of foreboding, that same
sense of completeness
that you could get in a short
story by Nathaniel Hawthorne,
like "The Minister's Black
Veil" or "Goodman Brown."
That's what you hear.
You hear the American
Gothic, the sense of curse,
the sense of deviltry.
So I want to play this
song one more time and talk
a little more about it.
[MUSIC - GEESHIE WILEY, "LAST
KIND WORDS BLUES"]
It was a privilege being
able to talk with you today.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]